a woman who could crack her back your
back with her feet yes I'm just gonna
say yeah like yeah like a rub-and-tug
yes yes but like the matter lady relax
eating something weird on the train yes
yes yeah it looks like big pieces of
green paper yeah your nose I'm sorry are
you chewing bark yeah an old Asian an
old Asian lady when they go with their
nose to they go finger it's hard to
describe it goes in and then they get
really up and they throw it up I'll
knock it down they almost get your thumb
they almost get their thumb up there too
if you're trying to pull it off the roof
there really are the harlem
globetrotters of nose white people are
the generals we're just like
[Music]
the bonfire comedy center radio sirius
XM 95 on big jokes and that's Dan Soder
its weapons day weapons karate day on
the bond force weapons and cookie day
some delicious cookies are delicious
cookies our guests joining us in studio
right now you know him as the co-host of
the Anthony Kunia show on compound media
it's Dave landau somepony's good to see
you man I got weapons and a cookie just
walking in the door dude welcome to the
bonfire thanks for having me that's what
we do we hand out a baseball game in the
Asians come in we try to represent a
little sweet side a little danger I like
it I feel dangerous and sweet got me a
full-blown like attack post - that's
nice yeah where we broke for Christmas
break yeah we've had conversations on
the show before about post apocalyptic
weaponry oh yeah what you would want to
use Jay wanted a bo staff
I wanted to hatch it so he got me an
all-purpose hatchet like a heavy duty
one before Christmas that's not hatchet
yeah that is nice to catch it what's
that it's an attach it and attach what
do you attach it to him just a lot
longer hatchet I wish I'm gonna look for
that I want it's got a cool side holster
oh that's really caring Walking Dead
style yeah that's awesome yeah so so we
went through all of our weapons and then
I since he got me that hatchet I had to
get him a real deal bo staff of
course so I mean this is a real the way
to that I think this is a legit legal
problem I like that it's you rarely see
a retractable most actually I rarely see
uh but if you could imagine I'm afraid
I'm gonna hurt someone
all right no I'm max I'm a no
you're not directly a Jacob aiming him
yeah that is riot police Wow it's a
double sided at the end of requiem for a
dream oh it's pre scream ass to ass when
you flick it out - yeah ass to ass he
has to ass
ass to ass ass to
would you say that's how you requiem for
a dream I feel like if I was using this
I would have been killed already
yeah you guys trying to figure that guys
give me more time but the beauty is once
it's extended you can spin it in a way
I'll show you one day Dave train we
could block bolts with Jay lives in the
shadows he blocks bullets I'm a leader
in an underworld anything doesn't matter
are you caught up in the our Kelly
scandal is there a new one I mean just
you know his whole exist well they just
put three series out I missed it I
missed the show yesterday and Jay went
in on it yeah when it's the documentary
series is it's just mind blow
like how he paid for a family to go to
like Paris so they didn't show up in
court I haven't even gotten to that in
the documentary as I'm going through it
oh wow normally but I watched a lot of
pieces of it over the course of the
weekend and I said I'm just blown away
by the whole thing and then realized
that uh I think I did check out on him
because I think when the whole pissed
tape came out I was like yeah he's just
done that's it like he's gone this many
years ago already just have Chappelle
show 20 but was a while it's like 2002
yeah seniors yeah I want to piss on you
yeah it's pretty early for sure I wanna
[Music]
I was great is so funny but they uh when
I don't think happened I just assumed he
was kind of like done but he just kept
releasing stuff and paying people off I
didn't know that I just was like every
time he popped back up this guy's doing
it yeah assume looks listen you know the
retraction is always the little blurb
and the accusations the headline you
know I mean so maybe they figured out he
didn't do stuff and he was by the way
acquitted of all charges of child
pornography somehow routine counts he
gets acquitted yeah he's like Al
Capone he's a brought up on several more
than that well he did do one yeah where
he got basically off on the technicality
because the family was just gone on
vacation over the trial so he just I'll
tell you what I really needed this trip
I mean everything bearing down with the
trial oh
today today well these flame tickets
aren't refundable egg on my face
like the piss from his dick he's gonna
walk it's like our kid all over the face
the most the most jarring thing about
that video to me was that he took a
full-length toilet piss on her he did he
really wasn't squirts yeah he gave her a
league of their own
yeah thanks know he had like a before he
did it he should have come into the
picture like jumping there's almost a
Naked Gun Leslie Nielsen but I when I'm
watching it so this documentary is just
revealing how much of a sick piece of
this guy realizes but in sequence
that I'm watching it now I started the
first episode getting into the whole
like a Lea thing like she was any like
have her family marry her well she was
15 I think they said she got pregnant
and gonna marry her the marriage
certificate said she was 18 he was 27
for sure the documentary have his music
in it playing through just to make it
fun the parts yet when they talk about
the song well I said this is the biggest
thing to me that I think you'll find
interesting but I did bring it up
yesterday it's just that the lady who
started the me to movement describes why
he's going through the cracks so much
with things is every time an allegation
came out is like lined up with the
release of a song that just changed
again he was like taking a dump on Ally
I think I think they said they use a
ignition remix is the thing I mean
everybody forget and then step in the
name of love made everybody forget him
and she goes you believe this guy this
may be black blue shake his head
yesterday so it made me laugh black blue
shaking his head cuz I go she says
basically you know a black people are
when it's a song that like you have to
barbecue you want to hear the family
reunion or that's your jam at the club
you know black people just kind of you
don't want to believe it you're like
yeah holy
well nobody's pissing on a kid right
then yeah so you got to drink the beers
first I don't know your background
enough Dave - no but I'll tell you if
you'd like to know that our Kelley's
music oddly good to piss on kids - yeah
say this it is a very calming stream
like music yeah you can relax
it much like it is much like running
water in the city I go I'm a little
stopped um can you guys get some r.kelly
on real quick uh oh there we go he goes
does he sleep is he asleep you just put
on Kelly washing piss himself put on
half on a baby do you want to see me of
mrs. PJs I swear to god that kid will
just leak put on our Kelly put it's in
for water yes it's it's kind of like
Elvis like Elvis lumpfish love
well he didn't you didn't like piss but
he liked kids he liked young yeah so
like karate that it's weapons day like
basically the last five years of his
life was just him in Vegas doing karate
and a bra with that down the last time
on the last five my career but watch the
karate talk dude black belt in karate
pants with patches from various
tournaments like I did not see him under
the kimono you're in full samurai gear
damn well - yes so I'm watching the LIA
thing when they say with the Lea part
they're talking everyone around him
going like hey you're not ally
or he's like I'm just produced under
guys relaxed and they're like nah but
seriously she's 15 like you know you
really and they go I wish the more
you keep asking the weirder is then they
would do what's his actual first name
Robert Robert so there's this some
Chicago cop that works a
security detail he goes Robert I'm not
gonna lie to you if you are having sex
with Ally it is highly illegal dude I
worked murder police North Chicago for
damn near 20 years if you're a
kid you got to tell me about it or
they're gonna rain
on us but no how many time rain down
what is it you're doing this girl what
are you doing to shower carp in your
hotel room dude I can't tell you please
SEC SEC still the best thing is how many
times there's screenshots on the
documentary show yeah that goes Robert
Kelley then was brought up on 22 counts
of child pornography I might take a
picture and send it to Bobby yes not
funny
dude why would you do that dude you know
what the feds read that there
looks different did it say only
unfortunate just because this
documentary came out so now everybody
calls him Robert I no problem for the
last 20 years it's always are I know now
he's Robert Kelly there's Bobby Bobby
Bobby Kelly heat so the Aaliyah thing
they're saying he's like no you guys are
not stop even asking it's stupid then
they start doing all kinds of weird
things like going on TV a lot together
dressed in the same thing but not the
same thing like stylish Li the same
thing
like they just got off a plane from
Disney World we bought the same merch
yeah yeah yeah so wait they're like all
the airport shirts but the same Arab
Nicky like Mickey Mouse like green like
with part flannel part regular charts
and it's written for tchen Utley
alia got on the wrong flight yeah yeah
but it's so funny when you're a
pedophile and you dress like your victim
oh I know well look at you oh yeah no
biggie muscle school organizer like look
at Corey Feldman who dresses like
Michael Jackson yeah you're stepping
into it got Corey Feldman
oh I'm not knocking the guy oh we
destroyed him he hates us we are all
blocked no its reply yeah and we stacked
his live concert and start a chance to
got him all juiced up and he still
blocked us really yeah but don't worry
he kind of went around it we're gonna
buy a cameo from him oh there you go
we'll buy an apology stay tuned for
whatever part 2 oops don't move sit down
and watch another episode of the bond
front sit see
sit down sit no pack leader
No